11 ans qui est le narrateur de la
comtesse ou king
orson welles
carte
césar et maître panisse mangel né à la
belote au bar de la marine aujourd'hui
nous préférons triplé nos lettres au
scrabble acheter les hôtels de monopoly
démasquer le coupable au cluedo et
surtout trouver les bonnes réponses du
trivial pursuit le trivial et distribue
en france par kenneth parker qui obtient
grâce essentiellement à ce jeu un
chiffre d'affaires de 700 millions de
francs si vous réfléchissez qu'est ce
qu'il ya comme jeux pour adultes vous
apercevez que les jeux pour adultes
avant trial poursuites c'est le bruit je
le scrabble les échecs ce sont des jeux
qui sont plutôt intellectuels qui sont
pas très amusant je crois que le grand
succès de trivial pursuit c'est que
c'est effectivement peut-être le premier
jeu pour adultes dans lesquelles les
gens s'amusent énormément qu'est ce que
la mère michel a perdu dans la chanson
le jeu a mis du temps à s'imposer et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui ça paraît bizarre
quand on voit l'engouement que ce jeu
en france aujourd'hui la raison pour
cent et simple que lorsqu'on a introduit
le jeu et allez ça ressemble à une boîte
de chocolats c'est un jeu en fait de
questions et de réponses ce qui en soi
n'est pas d'une originalité
extraordinaire s'est vendu à un prix qui
est quand même largement supérieur à
celui de tous les autres jeux sur le
marché et en plus c'est un nom tout à
fait imprononçable donc quand vous
arrivez sur le marché avec un produit de
ce type la première réaction de
l'ensemble des gens qui on joue le jeu
était de penser que ça ne marcherait
jamais et lorsque nous avons introduit
le jeu en france en 1984 il y avait
vraiment très peu de gens qui croyaient
au potentiel de ce dans le trivial des
questions animalière par exemple combien
dieu un ver de terre at-il réponse aucun
l'histoire de france aussi est présente
qu'elle roady après moi le déluge
réponse louis 15 ça finit par déclencher
la révolution
[Musique]
une autre question du trivial sur marat
assassiné dans son vin par charlotte
corday mara travail est toujours dans sa
baignoire pourquoi la réponse dans un
instant remuer vos méninges ce fut
d'ailleurs le premier titre du trivial
pourrait y ont pris la décision de le
lancer sous le nom de remue-méninges ton
de sombre et assez amusant et est assez
bien adapté au jeu et après environ six
mois de commercialisation
les inventeurs sont venus nous voir et
nous ont dit que compte tenu du succès
mondial de ce produit il tenait à
maintenir à travers le monde le nom de
marque il voulait en quelque sorte que
ce soit le coca cola du jeu de société
qu'il était l'homme de l'année potable
en 1938
[Musique]
toute connaissance est une réponse à une
question nous dit le trivial pursuit qui
nous incite à tester notre culture déjà
quatre cent trente mille questions été
rédigé pour les différentes versions du
jeu un important travail de
documentation on voit le trivial pursuit
c'est surtout trop trouver quel des
questions drôle c'est à la fois apporter
une information quand même un côté un
peu un peu d'humour je dire on n'est pas
là pour s'ennuyer on est là pour
s'amuser moi je me souviens d'une
question c'était tellement de
l'assistant de géo trouvetou
bon la question je pense que les gens
vont dire mais si j'ai dû mais si je
connaisse le journal de mickey tu te
souviens tu as lu ça tout le monde a lu
ça et on se souvient pas forcément que
c'était finalement parce que c'était une
petit bonhomme avec une ampoule
électrique moins bien passé
c'est sympa d'isabelle vous pouvez vous
vanter d'avoir collé un nombre de gens
assez important la vapeur est renversée
c'est moi qui pose des questions aux
antilles combien étaient les marx
brothers quatre bonnes réponses quel
était le nom de la ligne fortifiée belge
en 1939
je sais plus j'imagine aussi écrit ben
voila ca c je passe des chiffres et jean
canal albert à la dernier oui c'est vrai
j'ai gagné un
kid antoine de cléopâtre meurt le
premier dans la pièce de shakespeare je
crois bien que c'est antoine bonnes
réponses et au fait pourquoi mara
travail est il dans son bain il fallait
répondre parce qu'il souffrait d'une
maladie de peau
[Musique]